[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm kabhi HD here
and welcome to a new version of android
already this is Android P it's one of
those incremental updates again new
letter versions aren't those like
massive drastic changes anymore like
they used to be back in the day but that
makes sense when they've been refining
Android for so long they're kind of
tweaking things at this point but that's
never stopped us and we have the
Developer Preview on this pixel too and
it's worth noting that there are some
actually pretty cool new things so these
are the five biggest new feature changes
to Android P so number one is the new
visuals and there's just a couple
smaller things it's just a general look
and feel of a few tweaks you might not
even notice them if I didn't point them
out but first of all the clock is over
to the left corner now it used to be on
the right and still it changes color if
you have a dark wallpaper it'll be a
light clock if you have a light
wallpaper it'll be dark and that's also
along with all the buttons on the bottom
the date and the weather the app drawer
also now has this more defined dock
instead of a gradient shade behind it so
it's more obvious I think that may
affect the way people make their
wallpaper choice but again it's
obviously pretty minor you might not
notice but then the biggest main thing
is these quick settings up at the top
here everything is first of all in these
circles now it's this blue and white
look and really what you're gonna notice
is this is definitely part of a larger
theme here if you pay attention you're
gonna start to notice a lot of rounded
corners and smoothed off edges in
Android P so number two is those quick
settings and this is one of those things
in Android that they always seem to
tweak and like every new version they
can't really make up their mind on how
they want it to look so they've changed
it again here so they have like I said
these circles for everything and the new
blue and white look that's also new with
the color and then now if you have
enough quick settings it's this
vertically scrolling list now instead of
a left-to-right paginate at UI and it
has you know this big obvious bar at the
bottom so it's generally a little bit
cleaner and more obvious where things
are at you know what I don't like though
is you can't long press to expand these
toggles anymore and I get that quick
settings are supposed to be quick it's
just a one press toggle but that was
really useful if you had a bunch of
Wi-Fi networks on you long pressed you
could get in and explore them or a bunch
of Bluetooth devices that's gone for
some reason here I don't like that so if
you long press and
the settings in Android P here it just
does what it did in older versions of
Android which is just taking you back
into the menu alright so number three is
the new volume controls this is
definitely my favorite change so far so
first of all pressing the volume buttons
adjusts the media volume by default so
that's pretty sweet and you can see here
it's in this bar over at the side now
it's out of the way instead of that huge
thing across the top it goes up and down
instead of left to right so now it
matches the volume button on the phone
which is cool I think you could probably
be a little bit smaller just this this
whole bar UI is pretty big for just the
volume but overall I like you being over
here now and then there's this button at
the bottom to switch between ringer
modes so vibrate or silent or volume on
and then that arrow at the top is to
view your connected devices so if you
have some Bluetooth speakers or if it's
connected to your wireless headphones or
your car bluetooth or something they'll
all show up here so I'm I'm a fan of
this layout and then number four is the
new Settings app and again this is one
of those things that seems to change in
every new letter of Android but they've
changed it again here so with Android P
they got some color in there all the the
icons are big round colorful circles on
the side but it's not too cartoonish I
mean every icon is a different color but
then you get into the actual settings
menus and they look the same as they
were before so it's pretty clean and
then up top again you'll notice the
Settings search bar is this super huge
rounded I don't know it seems like
they've rounded every single corner
possible mixed feelings about this
generally I think it could look cleaner
with rectangles but hey that's the way
we're gone and then number 5 last but
certainly not least is not support in
the developer preview it's a little more
of an indication of our future than it
is a feature so if you go into settings
and display and themes there is actually
a couple different themes that simulate
a notched at the top of the phone and so
this is so developers can see what their
app would look like on a phone that
actually has a notch so they can see
what the behavior looks like and make
sure everything still works and it's
laid out properly so there's a small
narrow notch at the top like the
essential phone might have or a medium
one or even the big unibrow one like the
iPhone 10 has so obviously it's it's
weird to have a virtual notch cut out on
the top of a phone that already has
bezel x' but again this is a develop
preview and this is a tool for
developers to make their apps to support
the phones that we know are coming that
have notches in them
remember there's already some Android
phones coming out including the ones
that already exist with a notch in the
top does this embracing the knotch mean
pixel too will have a notch no but it
also doesn't mean pixel won't have
enough I don't know that's just kind of
where we're at right now welcome to 2018
but yeah that's the main gist of it
those are the top five I told you it was
a small update but uh in case you're
curious here a couple of other
interesting things worth noting that are
also pretty useful so when you have
rotation lock on in Android P and you
rotate the display anyway it'll give you
a little button in the corner just in
case you want to manually rotate what
you're doing this one time that is handy
you can now mark up screenshots as soon
as you take them that's built-in so I
guess pretty much exactly what iOS just
started doing now but it's a welcome
addition battery saver mode can now be
toggled on automatically at any battery
percentage between five and seventy
percent so for those of you who get
paranoid with a half battery this will
make you a little happier and there's
also now something called lockdown mode
which essentially will just disable your
fingerprint reader and any other smart
unlock method until you put in your
pattern or pin again seems pretty
pointless but if someone could in theory
walk up behind you and put your finger
on the fingerprint and run away they
could get away with your info unless you
have locked on mode on so again for
those of you who are paranoid oh and
text selection now has a suite zoom lens
which lets you more precisely select
text that is awesome and also an
important behind-the-scenes change is
that background apps cannot use the
microphone or camera anymore or any of
the sensors for that matter in Android P
we had always wanted that to be a thing
that we can individually control but now
that's an OS wide thing again if we're
paranoid we shouldn't be with Android
pay Android paranoid is that the new
probably not but that's basically it
those are your your main changes with
Android P mostly those little visual
tweaks I think I like the changes for
the most part except for I think those
circles are gonna take me some time to
get used to as far as the naming goes we
don't know what the P stands for yet my
money is on top look at this Easter Egg
how could it not be peppermint with all
those swirls in the Easter Egg it's got
to be anyway I'm gonna link an Android
police post below they do a great job of
tearing through new versions of Android
when they come out and digging through
the code and finding literally every
single new feature whether it's been
enabled or not so if you're interested
in the little stuff I'll link that below
the like button but that's pretty much
it how many what you guys think of the
big stuff the new stuff thanks for
watching talk to you the next one peace